-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The White House announced on
Friday that President Biden had
a cancerous skin lesion removed
from his chest.
And the lesion is already
running two points ahead
of DeSantis.
[ Laughter ]
Former president Trump
attended CPAC over the weekend
and told reporters he would not
drop out of the 2024 election
if he's indicted on criminal
charges.
You know, we compare him
to a mobster all the time,
but now he's literally saying,
"No problem,
I can still run things
from the joint."
[ Laughter ]
In his speech over
the weekend at CPAC,
former president Trump
said that before he came along,
the Republican Party was run
by freaks and fools.
Yeah. Nothing like the
Rhodes scholars we have today.
That's like going to Orlando
and saying, "You know,
it wasn't always this nice."
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump Jr.'s
fiancee Kimberly Guilfoyle spoke
over the weekend at CPAC, and
it looked like a rousing speech
until they cut to the audience.
Take a look.
>> All of us in this room have
one message to Joe Biden --
it is time to put America first!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Which brings us to a segment
called "Where is Everybody?!"
♪♪
Where is everybody?
I've never seen a theater
that empty, and I used to do
long-form improv.
[ Laughter ]
I've been in elevators more
crowded than that.
Where is there --
Did they accidentally schedule
you against Kid Rock karaoke?
That speech must have taken
twice as long
just to account for the echo.
Speaking of,
why are you yelling?
It's not like you need to play
to the back of the house.
And what's this,
"All of us in the room
have one message for Joe Biden."
You're the only one there.
There couldn't be a second
message in the room
for Joe Biden.
If anything, that room
has one message for you --
bring it way down.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been
"Where is Everybody?!"
It's a hit.
It's a hit new segment.
[ Laughter ]
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
spoke yesterday
at the Ronald Reagan
presidential library.
Specifically, he said
"All these gotta go."
[ Laughter ]
TV host Rachael Ray has
announced she's ending
her talk show after 17 seasons.
She made the decision in less
than 30 minutes,
but at home,
it would take you two hours.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't do great.
Better than I thought
I would do.
So that's kind --
I'm not saying it's a win/win.
It was definitely a win/lose,
but...
A woman in Florida recently set
a Guinness World Record
by winning 23 ultra-marathons
in 23 days.
In less happy news, her car
is basically undrivable now.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, United Airlines has
announced it will offer
T-Mobile customers free Wi-Fi
on all flights,
and Spirit announced that
they're gonna fly really close,
and you should be able to hop on
their network.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Good Photoshop.
That was the monologue,
everybody.